this is kind of my signature i've
created i've created this um talk within
the last year um
because believe it or not i've been in
this space for about six or seven years
but i think the last year was
has been a year of of codifying all of
the things that i've learned uh as a as
a designer a design researcher and a
design leader in the mlai space so
uh so i've been trying to put it into
to something that's concrete and
frameworks that people can understand
about what's different about this field
and how we're addressing some of the um
some of the not so nice outcomes that
come from uh humans engaging with
machines so hopefully
at the end of this you can walk away
with a little idea of what design in an
automated future uh i
at least from my point of view will look
like and i call it this the birth of ai
ml design because i really do feel like
we are crossing this the the the line
into a new way of doing design
um that is different than interaction
design and different than the industrial
design and all the other design
disciplines that we've had before so
uh
this is my design ethic statement this
is my design ethic statement uh i make
my students write one and i had a
student say well what's yours and so i
had to write my own uh i was a
journalist for a long time and when you
join when you become a journalist you
join a organization called the society
professional journalist and it's kind of
like a place where you learn how all the
moral codes that you're supposed to
follow in your profession and i was when
i became a designer i was kind of
waiting for that to happen like i was
waiting for my um you know uh design
ethics uh guidebook and and and
frameworks and and and card you know and
none came so uh i started on a journey
with my students actually to create
my own design ethics principle um and
framework and so this is mine to amplify
the beauty of humanity with design while
voting practices that exploit its
fragility
so if you don't have one i encourage you
to
get on that journey to create one for
yourself
about me
uh yes
said uh i
i am head of uh
head of i'm a head of design for machine
learning and responsible ai and and
machine learning governance and i want
to kind of unpack that because i think
my my job kind of tells us where we are
with machine learning and ai design
right now um
uh it used to be just
the the technology right of of how we
create models and how we create uh ai
and ml and now people are really
thinking about like how do we explain
those creations and so you have
something like what's called um machine
learning governance where where you have
separate a separate process where you
kind of analyze and uh and audit your
machine learning um creations to to look
for things like bias and
and um discrimination
as well as equity and and some other
things and then and then you have what's
called responsible ai which is this
whole other field of outside of
compliance and governance um
how how should these uh machine models
uh interact with with the human
population with society with individuals
with communities and so i am
and then and then i i'm on a metal level
with my team we actually are the design
team for the machine learning platforms
so our users are data scientists and
model developers so we design for them
so our research is really about how they
do their processes and the world
domination plan is i get to embed rai
and equity principles into the model
development process right so
uh i really feel very lucky to be able
to do that my jam has always been into
in design i love rapid prototyping i've
always kind of fallen and i've fallen
into enterprise software design so
i've always designed system
architectures and software like apis and
databases and all that kind of stuff and
i think that allowed me kind of like to
understand the machine learning uh and
ai systems design kind of framework a
little bit better i also am an adjunct
professor teaching designing ethical ai
at the school of design in depaul here
in chicago
so this is me i have 30 years this is me
as a baby and me in fourth grade and
then all the way up i used to work at
ideo i used to work at microsoft i
worked as a journalist
both domestic and internationally
i was like uh doing
anthropology research like i've had a
really varied background i've also
worked with
companies in all kinds of industries
financial healthcare human resources
automotive uh worked on self-driving
cars and
non-profit and government industries so
i have a really wide um
i have a ride narrative around design
and a ride narrative around technology
um and i i have a ba in communications
and and english and ms and computer
science so
um i think i wrote this
in interactions magazine last year when
when they lovingly asked me to write a
piece about what does design look in the
future
um that i feel like as a as designers
our roles will be to determine what not
to design in a quest to preserve human
culture values and rituals in our future
world i do believe we will get to a
point where machines will be able to do
almost anything that humans can do i
won't say everything that's singularity
but pretty close and
and i feel like as designers we're
probably in a unique position to kind of
hold up the stop and wait sign
and i think if we don't take that
responsibility we will run the danger of
creating products and platforms and
services that actually are
are
antithetical to human human nature and
human needs and and we don't want that
so here are some level setting
definitions i like to start off with so
everybody understands what point of view
i'm coming from uh and my mental model
uh this is my favorite definition of
design it comes from uh design
revolutionary victor papanick and if you
haven't read design for the real world
please do um design is the conscious and
intuitive effort to impose meaningful
order to chaos so again i'm putting
agency on design to to have a
responsibility to um to make sure that
we are imposing meaningful order to
something that is chaotic meaning a lot
of problems and issues in the world
so the first chapter when you want to
understand machine learning and ai
design is you have to understand data um
and from the oxford dictionary uh or
data as people say but when i say data i
always think of star trek so um i just
say data instead data is things known or
assumed as facts making the basis of
reasoning or calculation i love that
fact that it says known or assumed as
because i think it really kind of sets
the spectrum of what data could be
um
i this is this is my t-shirt mantra uh i
think i'm gonna get online and create a
whole fleet of these i usually make
people in the audience repeat this so
that people really understand that data
is created by people and people create
data
we as humans have a long history of data
we have a long history of i identity
being formatted in data how tall are you
uh when were you born uh how many
siblings do you have like all of that is
data right like who you are as a person
is made up of data and the reason why i
like to start with this is especially
when i'm talking to data scientists and
technologists
is the idea that when we're using data
to create these amazing complex models
that the we're using identity
we're using people right like we're
we're not just using ones and zeros and
i think that's really important to set
the stage right off the bat
and as designers who are human-centered
designers the idea that we belong in
those rooms when things are being
decided because we are the people
experts and so if anything is being
created with data then that means it's
being created with people and then that
means we belong
so does anybody know what this is
you guys are smart so you probably
already know what this is anybody i
don't know
um
i don't know if you can talk to the chat
or not but
um
this is what's known as um
uh a shirley card
and i want you guys to look at this
little label right here it says normal
what what does what does that make you
feel when you look at this
and you see that word normal
i just want you to think about that a
little bit
and maybe we can talk about it later
christina horrified
yeah as a black woman it makes me feel
excluded right like it makes me feel
like i'm not normal because i certainly
don't look like shirley
so shirley cards are historical in
photography kodak started it kodak was
the first company to go from black and
white to color photography
and i don't know how much you know about
photography but i used to work at a
newspaper back
that was those things that they used to
deliver at your homes i know you guys
don't have those but those used to be
printed not digital and when you're
doing a newspaper you had to color
correct right because
of you're using plates that were
combining colors to make cues rather
than you know having it digitized and
all that good stuff so you had to make
sure that when you were taking a color
photo that it was perfectly what they
call white balance
a very interesting uh word there as well
so when you were taking a photo you had
to like actually put a white sheet of
paper in front of the camera lens to
make sure that the photo was balanced
correctly so that the hues that would
come out of your color photo was where
the right hues were normal but the
problem was when kodak decided that they
were going to go from black and white
photography to
um to color and they had to create uh a
balancing um uh spectrum for that so
that they're um
so that the technology could recognize
what was normal and what was to the left
or to the right of normal lighter or
darker um
the this one guy this one engineer had a
calendar and it had this woman on it and
he thought this was
this would be the way that we could
calibrate all color photos um and well
what happened was when they used a woman
who was a white woman to normalize color
photography everybody who wasn't her
skin color who was darker than her
was
was basically made invisible so when you
look at old photographs polaroid kodak
whatever this is adopted around the
industry you would look at i would look
at photographs when i was growing up and
half of my family
you couldn't see because they were so
dark
um and you would think like okay uh vox
media did a whole piece on this it was
really great you were thinking like okay
we've advanced in technology
you know
light years from the shirley cards they
they really don't do that today
well um a legacy of shirley cards is
bias and facial recognition so you take
photography right and so it's biased
against darker skin and so people become
almost invisible when trying to
replicate that in print right now you
move to things like led lights right
what their color balance they're color
balanced the same way right it's
institutionalized and so now you go into
a hotel and i put my hands under a
faucet right and and it doesn't
recognize
my dark skin but my white friend they do
it and it recognizes it and so the water
comes out
and now okay so that's an led and then
now you get to uh facial recognition
software which by the way is about
ninety percent accurate but that 10
percent
black females like myself have a have a
huge problem being recognized by facial
recognition technology and all of that
all of that lineage from the shirley
cards all the way to today like google
just released a new version of their
phone other of the of the camera phone
that can now quote unquote recognize um
darker skin
um
that's been a long time in the making
but black people have been around
forever and so i i use this kind of like
make a a very um pointed example of we
only measure what someone says matter so
data define is biased data so if anybody
tells you that any ml or ai algorithm is
not biased i i just have to challenge
that because our institutional and
systematic racism sexism and ableism and
a lot of things go into who we are
and who we define at what matters and
what kind of data we want to use and
therefore really kind of
starts off our our process and machine
learning ai in a biased narrow view
it's not like black people weren't
around when
google and apple
and other technology companies created
uh camera phones right um it's just that
we weren't counted in in the color
spectrum and so
we only measure what someone says
matters right and if and if lgbtq people
um if the u.s census decides that
not marking that you are of
that that's part of your identity then
then does that make you invisible
you know it wasn't until this year the
u.s census even thought about um
counting lgbtq people right so i think
it's really important as designers is if
we want to kind of create human centered
ai and ethical ai really got to start at
the beginning and the beginning is the
data that is either omitted and not used
in models or used in a way that
perpetuates systemic racism sexism and
and and um and ableism
so this is part of my ten commandments
of mindful ai uh for us to remember that
this is how we start off with these
systems
we're using
data that's biased because we defined it
same with fico scores right um capital
one actually doesn't use fico scores we
use a we we use we use information from
from the three um um credit viewers but
we use it differently um and i think
it's really important that people
understand that you don't have to fall
into these systematic um
institutionalized
data uh creation places you can you can
use data in a different way to be more
fair and to be more equitable and i i
like to use the fico score because it's
it's this was fico
was created by white
engineer in 1958 to help banks
kind of decide
credit worthiness right it's
been the same formula i won't say the
same but mostly the same formula since
1958 and a lot of people don't like to
mess with it because it has
institutional legacy
which
inherently has institutional bias i mean
what was going on in 1958 redlining
um people weren't getting mortgages
because of this their color their skin
their sexuality um their religion um
there were a lot of things that were
going on in 1958 that statistically we
have not
vetted out of a system like fico
so
i i have these examples is that data is
the lifeblood of ml and ai if you
uh are looking to
um make sure that human centered design
products that are being viewed about ml
and ai are equitable and ethical and
take into account human needs all that
you have to start with the data that
goes into those systems
data and people are irrevocably linked
so all all people create data and
keeping people in the forefront of data
aggregation ensures more human
intelligent product design
that is integral to ml and i without
data there's no machine learning no
artificial intelligence and it's
important that we as designers really
understand how data is collected how
it's cleaned and it's cleaned how it's
engineered
and how it's transformed
by data data scientists and model
developers to ensure human-centered ai
and data practices ultimately dictate an
ai user experience so biased data
creates bias machine learning models
missing data creates bad machine
learning outcomes
that affect people just
disproportionately
in different ways and so ultimately a
company's data practices will dictate
whether it's a human-centered ai whether
it has a human-centered ai experience or
outcome
some terms i think you should be aware
of if you're not already uh if you want
to go into this field is unstructured
data this is data that isn't easily
labeled or stored or categorized which
means we have more opportunities as
humans to influence how that data is
engineered and read
some examples include text and pdf
images uh word documents then we have
structured data this is cleaner than raw
data this has been labeled this has been
categorized uh like speed limits right
things like that and it usually is ready
for data analysis or visualization it's
also i have a little stop sign here
because i think it's also
an alert place with a structured data
it's also biased data because it comes
because somebody has to label it and
categorize it and give it meaning so
uh structured data goes from just kind
of loose data that somebody right some
process uh categorizes it and then it
becomes then it has meaning right and so
you have to really look at those
meanings when when people structure data
um and then there's explicit data this
is information that is provided
intentionally by people so i sign in i
log up i fill out a registration form
you know exactly why i'm putting that
data in then there's implicit data this
is information not provided
intentionally but gathered from
available data streams either directly
or through analysis of explicit data so
for example when you click a thumbs up
it's implied that you like that content
right
i also have red stops there because a
lot of implicit data is used to make
what i call contextual leaps and without
qualitative data to back behi to back
that up you don't really know what's
happening when that data is created it's
really important that data is contextual
it's not just something that you collect
and then shove into a model right you
really need to understand where that
data comes from and why it was created
so facts to remember again all data is
created by people so
uh don't divorce people from their data
one of the biggest sins in unethical ai
or or what i would call um not
human-centered ai is the sin of omission
so creating a model that makes decisions
that has a lot of missing data so if the
us census was to create a model to
decide
um who in the lgbtq community could
receive um
benefits for example
i would i would i would question that
because those folks weren't included
into
uh census counts until this year so
there's a lot of missing um
last year there's a lot of missing data
variables there and then lastly and the
number one uh commandment from
uh over ten commandments of of mindful
ai is that is not truth that is not the
unbiased unchallenged input as
advertised it's the version of the truth
that depends upon who's collecting
engineering categorizing and using it
data is always contextual it will never
stand on its own as as just truth
because data is not true we have to work
to detect and reduce bias in it right
that doesn't mean our machine learning
models need to
uh perpetuate the historical biases that
come with things like medical history or
medical experiments right lots of
medical experiments have been done but
most of them have been done on men
white men for sure so how do i know that
experiments for for diabetes medication
for example which disproportionately
affect people color is really the right
experiment for me to have good outcomes
on uh on my on my health as a black
woman um i think ml designers who work
with data scientists uh can help to
discover detect and reduce historical
biases and data collection before it
gets into the model that is so important
and that is part of machine learning
experience design if you want to be a
designer in this area your one of the
responsibilities is to is to see
uh what is going into those models and
to detect if historical biases are being
fed into a model i think designers could
pair you know our normal hcd methods
with bias reducing mathematical methods
to reduce bias before it becomes a model
outcome
i think it's important to acknowledge
and announce make data inputs and model
outcomes more of a glass box
in a black box announce the ingredients
in the recipe that you're creating right
uh that's that's has to do with
explainable ai which is what we're
working on
um be upfront about weak data and data
engineering not all data is good data
and that's okay but you need to kind of
like
um say that and model outcomes when
you're evaluating model goodness
and explainability is a legal
requirement but traceable and publicly
audible without ip violation is a higher
and better bar so i should be able to do
an audit on your on your algorithm to
see how it made its decision
because data is not true wrong data will
be occasionally used use this as an
opportunity for design don't just
abandon uh eliminating biases because we
know it's impossible um ml designers
create experiences to help users provide
model feedback that's one of our biggest
charges is to design ways for humans and
machines to have a reciprocal
relationship when they're going through
the machine learning powered experience
new better data helps to neutralize the
effects of bad data so you can't just
set it and forget it you can't just use
one data set over and over again there's
a thing called model drift where the
longer a model is in play the more
accurate it can become and you need to
detect that
so this is a nerd alert now that we've
gotten through data i i'm just going to
go quickly about how it's used in mlnai
and then go into mlnai capabilities
and give you kind of like an overview of
of of kind of the nerdy side of this
world hopefully this won't be too boring
for you guys
machine learning is a category of
artificial intelligence in which
computers learn to achieve a desired
outcome by applying problem solving
rules automatically after being trained
to do so
uh
data is fuel for all machine learning
models data scientists use algorithms to
use data to train and teach machines to
solve problems through models
algorithms are the lifeblood that
carries the fuel allowing machine
learning models to sense act and learn
um i've been told that data scientists
hate when people explain machine
learning uh as replicating the human
brain
um so i'm gonna have to switch that out
um
but basically uh i'll go through the
process of it and and then you'll see
uh how machine learning works
um
i think it's really important to
understand that we create algorithms
every day if it's raining outside you
have a rule that says i'll go grab a
hoodie or or umbrella that's just a
simple rule that happens every time
right and and that's an algorithm
socrates is said to have created the
first algorithm right it's analog but
it's still an algorithm
and
this is how the human brain processes
information if you're aci you've seen
this several times uh we have an
internal external stimuli it goes into
our brain we reach back into our sensory
information sometimes short term which
is always working sometimes long term
which takes longer to get to thinking
fast and slow those kinds of things we
recognize oh i've seen this before
looks like a flower it's yellow must be
a dandelion or must be a flower that
looks like that or it's red maybe it's a
rose those kinds of things and then we
go through a series of thought process
to decide how we're going to behave do
we pick it do we leave it alone do we
walk by those kinds of things
eerily familiar on the data on the
development of a model development
process of a of a
ml model
we get
internal or external stimuli usually
data from historical data or data from
ambient like the environment it comes in
that data is validated and recognized um
it it the
it's been trained on that data so the so
the model kind of goes back
into its memory and say oh i recognize
this data i've got rules to apply to
that data and so it behaves in that
applicable way
and then uh it
as a as the data scientist goes through
the process it kind of repeats this
process several times to get to a good
model goodness score meaning that the
model is replicating the same the
results that are asked for um at a high
accuracy rate um accuracy is only just
one way to to
to determine model goodness and then it
trains it again on data it's never seen
before just to make sure that they can
validate the results and then
it goes through the process again this
is the model development process
machine learning is used in anomaly
detection classification models netflix
i'm sorry classification models imaging
dog or cat recommendation models netflix
what kind of
movies do you like um these are examples
of machine learning in the real world
and then artificial intelligence is just
kind of like an umbrella of other ways
to do machine learning and other types
of um algorithmic based uh technologies
uh neural networks deep learning all
that um
and the the way that i like to separate
and this line is becoming more blurred
every day it used to be that machine
learning just did historical data and
artificial intelligence could do
real-time contextual data but now
machine learning algorithms have become
so strong they can do real-time uh
contextual data as well so um i don't
actually know where the line is going
but now they have something called
machine intelligence which is the
intersection of artificial intelligence
and machine learning and these are what
we call the deep neural networks and the
deep learning networks that places like
google and and and facebook and and even
some other places are getting into
um
the
i i think the key difference is is that
artificial intelligence really
transforms the information right um it's
transforming it so that decisions or
behaviors can be made um it's dynamic
right computers are using their
environment to do tasks rather than
depending on historical data
and
when compared when paired with other
technologies like iot ar vr you can
really have a machine see and hear and
taste and smell like write poetry and
smell bread and taste sugar and see the
drive it really kind of like
exponentially
um
creates new capabilities for ai and mo
um i like this this kind of like human
machine kind of like
mirrored uh uh i a mirrored side on
capabilities for ai and ml
um we see
ai power machines can see automatic cars
google search classification facial
recognitions we hear
ai can uh use auditory sensors to to
replicate sound and to hear and to
process sound we speak natural language
processing um um can and can have us
have contextual conversations through
alexa's series cortana eno we act uh
automation allows robots and dancing
robots from boston dynamics which are
really my favorite um and we make
decisions so recommendation models
netflix facebook twitter
so we're getting close so some key i uh
ai terms algorithms machine learning
deep learning uh does not require
step-by-step programming and can make
decisions on its own um narrow ai is
also known as weak ai
um this is where we are pretty much at
uh and then there's generative ai i had
this does not exist but it does this
scan this is when you see those really
amazing like art replicas that um that
ai can generate without ever going to
art school it's kind of
interesting if you've ever seen it and
then of course ai singularity and this
is really when ai machines become
self-aware this is the stuff of you know
irobot and uh octavia butler and some
other some other folks
now i'm
fairly certain this does not exist but
i'm not gonna you know bet the farm on
it
this is all how we use ai in the real
world it's everywhere i i think uh um
uh
there's a quote that like 75 of of
americans have some kind of ai powered
um device or product or service
um these are the capabilities
and i think it's really important to
know the limitations as designers this
is where we're going to spend most of
our time
uh which is kind of a bummer we will be
the negative nancy right like we are
definitely going to be like yes hey i
could do that but should it you know um
no data no dice right so um when i think
about the the right applicability or
desirability of ai i think about what
data is it going to be fueled upon
and if there's missing data categories
then i have to think it's kind of
suspect uh garbage in garbage out i also
think about ai and ml being applied to
systematic
and
um to being applied to systems that have
systematic racism in them like law
enforcement right
it's a red flag to apply ai and ml to a
system that has systematic problems with
its data including law enforcement hr is
another space um there are a lot of
different places that you have to be
really careful when you're applying ml
and ai
nuance is the enemy of machine learning
ai like it's very binary but but
individuals aren't right like we're
we're intersectional human beings and so
we really need to really kind of uh
scrutinize when we're using ml and ai
for human engagement and ml and ai's rep
is meant to replicate human rationality
but in reality humans are keenly
irrational
so this is just an example of ai
smelling
a friend of mine who i worked at when
microsoft built this uh smart device to
smell uh he he's he's parisian uh french
same as benjamin cave and he wanted a
better way to
see when his bread was uh uh
was um uh ready for i got uh slipping
ready for for baking a proof proofing
yeah
and he developed a way he had a tiny ml
and he had a raspberry pie and he put it
together and
and people are like oh wow how can ai
smell well smells have a combination of
chemicals right that is
that can be uh uh
numerous right like you you can have
certain kinds of combinations that
creates things that uh that you can
smell and so once you feed those into a
microcontroller that has an ai model
development component the the
the smart device can can detect
different uh nuances in in the numerical
uh makeup of the smell so now he built
something that can smell different
whiskeys it can smell coffee it can
smell bread it's it's a pretty cool
thing
and a fourteen-year-old used his uh
invention to
uh help build something that could
detect different smells uh and illnesses
it was kind of interesting
so what does all this mean i think uh
quickly here i think it means we have to
redefine what design and research is in
an automated future um
and here's my why for that and i'm
totally
with challenged on this but
over the years i've come to say that we
can't do things and design and research
the way that we've done an interaction
design if we want to create better human
centered ai products so the current
technology we have has a user who
controls the device it's usually in a
single agency sometimes it's a communal
thing but mostly it's like me and my
my my iphone or me and my controller or
me and my television or whatever we're
doing
the interaction is usually one way even
if it's in a group way the machine is
interacting with me in a way uh
it's usually a one-way street
um technology is task based right i want
to do this so i'm using the technology
to do x and it has affordances uh all of
my screens are looking the same i know
where the exit button is it's it's
pretty familiar to me
even if i've never seen this mobile
device before i can probably figure it
out right
because the device interacts with me in
the same consistent way
and it's static right the device
performs tasks in the same way it
doesn't really change it
yes there's updates but you know i i
know i'm gonna push a button right
i think with automated or intelligent
system technology the difference is the
user and machine can both be in control
they can be in control simultaneously
they can be in control at different
times and that presents a different flow
for experience design
uh the context of use is multi-agency so
you have the user you have the device
who are both sentient but you also have
an ecosystem of other devices that can
talk and engage and have relationships
so you have a self-driving car and the
and the driver you have another
self-driving car and driver and there's
the ability for them to all
you know kind of have engagement in this
in this intelligent ecosystem
interaction is is at least two-way right
like i i can talk to the machine and it
can talk back to me um with with a
sentient understanding of what i'm
saying
um technology use is decision based
right so so the machine exists to make
decisions right not just to do tasks
um and technology affordability can
change over time right so when i first
get my self-driving car i may
want to restrict a lot of experiences
with it because i don't trust it but
after i've been driving this car for a
while i may i may want to change that
spectrum of of of autonomy for the car
um so the affordance can change over
time so what does that mean for an
experienced designer
and technology is dynamic the machine
learns and performs differently with new
knowledge and for that means my
engagement will be different with the
machine over time so as designers you
have to think about that long tail
experience design that isn't the same
when the system the machine and the
human are first engaged
what does that look like for experience
design when we want to change that over
time right
so
i think we currently use methods that
aren't future oriented enough right
so it's really speculative
speculative research is different which
is difficult with current ux like
interviewing and stuff like that you
know people don't know what kind of
stargate they want research needs to be
more dynamic uh
not as static so we can't just interview
people once um and think okay we've got
confidence in design direction and
research has to go beyond single agency
framework uh and consider like ecosys
ecosystems
multimodal ai environments
um so we got to go beyond usability and
desirability i think we have to seek
unexpressed rituals culturals and values
at in irrational practices that humans
do when they're engaging with their
environment we can't just automate those
out right because for example when i was
working on this automation driving
project uh self-driving car project with
ford one of our recommendations was not
to take the steering wheel out which was
technologically like
illogical because you didn't need it
right because the car could drive itself
but humans have this
deep psycho
um
psychological need to control their
environment and they need to extend that
control with their hands right and so if
you don't have a control there
um
the the the people freaked out it was
just their mind cognitively couldn't
really comprehend that the car was
moving without them moving it
so
um how do i combat kind of like what i
saw was a lack of methodology for ml and
ai design um i found inspiration in
things like design anthropology
um design anthropology seeks to
understand how the processes and
artifacts of design help to define what
it means to be human it's just the other
way around instead of looking at
humanity and trying to try to um
make it fit with design you're looking
at the design of the human and seeing if
you can design things that fit into
humanity right
design anthropology is a method of
research that focuses on how design
translates human values into tangible
experiences so how do you design
trust
how do you design
uh understanding how do you
how do you design um privacy those kinds
of things
it it combines ethnographic field work
but it's iterative and it's both
reflection and and and action oriented
it's less
reliant on observing current states and
employs things like simulation mock-ups
props and tangible interactions to
explore futuristic and speculative
design
it's definitely co-participatory um it
it is it it requires the participant of
users uh to really get at understanding
of rituals and and and and values
uh and it's more scenario based so i use
a lot of games performances enactment
it's it's and teams are
transdisciplinary so each member is
working together to create new
conceptual theoretical meta and
and and methods um for innovation so
that means designers data scientists
engineers my team at capital one it's
made up with people with backgrounds in
physics and engineering and design and
education and sociology and anthropology
it's not just made up with people with
hci degrees
so design anthropology has
transdisciplinary multi uh
characteristics it requires that
co-participation
and its research-led design
um and it's iterative research is
designed and designed as research
there's no like concrete phase between
the two
and we use provocative prototypes and
simulations we put people in scenarios
so that we can understand because this
dynamic nature of ml and ai we don't
know the answers to many of the
questions that we have and the only way
that we can get more confidence in our
design directions is just to try to re
try to put people in futuristic
scenarios
so here's how i think we're gonna evolve
as designers we're we're gonna kind of
adopt a more hands-on
simulated
futuristic research methodology to
figure out what we should be designing
in this area um and and i think we'll
have a a broader framework of our design
so we'll look at people individuals and
systems rather than with a device right
and then we'll have multi-disciplinary
teams right like we'll hire diverse
designers from a wide range of
backgrounds and they won't be just
designers they'll be data scientists
product managers engineers
janitors people with all kinds of
different backgrounds to bring mental
models to to bear
and so it's designed today
is human centered um it focuses on
people's knees and it counteracts
counteracts adverse effects people
really forget that in the iso definition
of acd
hcd
i think tomorrow we'll have more
pluralistic um uh pluralism in design
direction we'll shift from universal and
we'll have like 15 different journeys
that that a person can go through that
we could customize and design and
automation will help us to do that we'll
go
um the type of data collection and
analysis will afford that kind of
individual customization at a massive
scale
um
the role of designer would kind of lose
its coveted elitism and apply to people
with skills not often connected to
design engineers anthropologists
hairdressers
um because the pluralism will demand
intersectional designers i believe we'll
move from device and individual to human
machine relationships
uh this ability to hyper customize will
push designers beyond our agency model
of interaction design to consider how
humans and machines have a cooperative
relationship together as the pinnacle of
that experience so really learning
having the human teach the machine what
she or he or they want rather than us
designing a journey for them that they
all must go down
and i i also believe will will hit
machine agency and autonomy
designers will have to consider the
agency not just of the humans but of the
machines and the ecosystem within the
which they operate this is like my way
out moonshine stuffs moonshot stuff so i
know it's kind of crazy
and we'll redefine design
we'll integrate
data science design to develop
intelligent products that improve
people's everyday lives this is my
definition of machine learning
experience design
and it'll be transdisciplinary we'll
have explorers we'll have builders we'll
chase loon shots those looney tune ideas
will will that would be our wheelhouse
we'll go after what seems impossible
as a designer will be more
interdisciplinary
um we'll have a bias towards building
things and just getting people in
environments rather than thinking
or conceptually talking about things and
we'll be forced to make abstract things
like trust and value concrete
we'll treat data as a stakeholder we'll
be less design centric and we'll have an
interdisciplinary focus which means
we'll focus on keeping people and data
together understand desata as a design
tool recognize the right applicability
for aiml
and understanding the real-time dynamic
nature of ml and ai and focus on
building to learn rather than our
designer in
intuition
and
really encourage participatory design
code design with people impacted by
these products
i i won't go through this because i
don't think i have time but
this was a project that i worked with
with the data scientists and researchers
and designers on redesigning um the
outpatient experience
uh for uh
for kids at a pediatric hospital
um and i think what i i really want to
point out here about
what was different about this was that
we defined data and systems as
stakeholders really early
in in this process so definitely we went
out and did qualitative interviews but
we also collected like three years of
employment data and started exploring
and looking at that data just like we
were exploring and talking to
patients and their families we
integrated data and field research
exploration and synthesis so while the
data scientist was doing exploration
he he he was putting that visualization
in the project room and we as as
researchers and designers were asking
very inquisitive questions about what he
was seeing we were talking about what we
saw on the data same thing with the data
scientist coming to us he conducted
qualitative interviews with folks and
and that kind of mix of mental models
was really great for us to get at what i
call parallel synthesis synthesis that
comes from different points of view to
come together to have a better insights
and so these data-infused research
insights allowed us to discover better
design opportunities
uh on the right are my qualitative notes
on the left are the quantitative notes
it's so great how they kind of like came
together and
it led us to this notion of variance and
how we could design for that
um
and some methods that we use were data
people journey mapping um this is
this is mapping data and people along
your journey mapping experience systems
mapping where does the data come from
where is the data created and
transferred and by whom and what
and doing you know
debriefing systems and data interviews
together as well as qualitative
interviews
and creating uh what does that mean
moments where where the different
disciplines can come together and ask
about their methodology
um
we were able to eliminate systems
challenges rather than individual
challenges only right when you think
about the user pain points we were able
to think about the user's pain points in
the context with the systems pain points
that allowed us to redesign the
ecosystem in a better way and we used
lots of simulations to test different
design outcomes and scenarios
this is one of those simulations the
kids loved it
um we we just basically redesigned their
whole experience of checking in and and
figuring out uh when they were going to
their next appointment
um
yeah that's it
i think i i left like six minutes for
questions
oh my gosh that was fantastic um
and while we're waiting um i've got to
say
one of the things we're both educators
here one of the things um
i think is hard to do is teach people
how to think about time so you talked
earlier about you know when you first
get in you won't trust the car
but then over time you start building
that trust and eventually you start
being willing to
um you know hand over more things
and i
i think it's a it's really hard to get
people to stop thinking of a moment and
get them yes
yeah they have to think about a spectrum
right and you have to design for that as
the car gets smarter should the
experience change right
and and sometimes you need the the user
to teach you that
when they're ready you can't just
say all right i'm gonna make the the
change happen and one of our principles
our design principles with that was
designed for the transition state not
in-state
so when you're when you're designing
with an autonomous vehicle you want to
make sure you don't miss the transition
um where it goes from
car to human or human to car
a lot of people designing for the
in-state right so now the car is in
control and you design that experience
or the humans in control but really it's
about that transition when they
switch control
that's the real experience you want to
design
i don't want to get too pragmatic and i
know god will interrupt me if there are
other questions but um are there some
techniques that are particularly well
suited to making those kinds of plans
you mentioned journey maps uh
you know they've become fairly standard
yeah i think the the thing about the
journey map is and this is uh an
alignment that i got from my students is
i the journey must that we do are are
very different because they're actually
not the user journey it's the system's
journey
and so you have to think about the user
is within a journey rather than the
journey that the user goes on and it's a
it's a it's a new it's a nuance in how
you do those mapping um but if you get
that nuance then you really understand
how to how to change the design and i
think
i i like to use an example of ordering a
pizza
because you can map out that journey
pretty easily yeah but um online um but
then when you when you go to map it
you're really going okay
how do they get the price of the pizza
that they want how do they decide what
kind of inner ingredients and all of
that stuff doesn't come from the user it
comes from different places within the
system and so now you're designing
around a user so that they can have the
experience that they want and so now
you're designing beyond what the user
wants and what the system can do
so you're thinking in terms of
architecture databases where the data
lives who has access to that like that
needs to be part of the design um
that makes sense um
you'll just let me know right okay
yes so as there are no questions
okay not not in the uh and i don't see
anything on chat so we're good um so
i'd like to dig in more into um the
ethics side of it um
you know uh
gosh i want to ask you so many questions
like how did you get into ethics but
also how do you bring ethics into the
work process
you know yeah and i think first of all i
think i i try not to use the word ethics
but i think it's a
because ethics is contextual right like
like my ethics and india if i my ethics
of the way that i operate in america is
one way and i've been to 65 countries
and i can tell you that if i go to other
countries about certain things are
allowed that i wouldn't do here in
america and it would be completely
ethical over there i think
that i think what we want to do is to
incorporate
do no harm
right as much as possible and whatever
that means right like i i'm not defining
that but i'm just saying like that's the
way we want to think
about when we're trying to do
human-centered or responsible or
whatever like i think it's really good
to just say hey we're going to start off
with acknowledging that there there
could be harm here so what kind of harm
does that look like so we do harms
modeling right this is the um uh un kind
of like you take the the u.n security
needs that they say everybody needs it's
like security identity privacy economic
access to economic freedom those kinds
of things and you you do an exercise
that goes
if i create this technology how does it
not only harm a person but in these
individual categories will it interve
who will it harm economically who will
it harm identity wise who would it harm
and
and you may find it doesn't but you need
to look at it in all of the
intersectionality there like on a global
kind of system scale rather than just
like are there gonna be is one person
gonna be hurt by this right
so when i when we talk about ethics i
think what i really am talking about is
being mindful
how mindful can you be that's why i call
it mindful ai so i'm i'm really
considering all the different things
that can happen with this model
thank you um i have a thousand questions
so i wish you weren't remote but uh
hopefully our our paths will uh meet
again and question in the auditorium
oh wonderful okay hi
and i wanted to ask um
so i'm not a cs major but um but i know
a bit of like ml techniques and like
a lot of it comes down to like data and
probability but when it comes to like
more
um
i would say qualitative
data it's a lot harder to capture them
and make it ai or like machine learning
you know algorithms or whatever it is
and i think a lot and a lot of it right
now like nowadays has been transiting
from like actual data to
uh human relations and emotions
and especially in this like
or like uh in this post-pandemic
era when people actually appreciate
human relationships a lot more so
i mean how does like a company like
yours like actually look into this more
human relations or like emotional part
yeah i love that you asked this question
because this is exactly what i'm
wrestling with right now and
i
okay so here's here's how i talk to it
to to my company
so what a lot of people don't really
understand is that banks are heavily
regulated and when and when we talk
about regulation non
non-fair lending practice discrimination
all that that extends to our models by
the way
so
we have a a higher bar or burden
i won't say burton but a higher bar of
of fairness and awareness
um and and and explainability and all
that kind of stuff because we're banks
um and so all the things that we were
doing in in anything that we did in our
practices it extends to iraq technology
by the way and we're audited by that
but i talked to my risk officer all at
my chief risk officer all the time
we have definite indicators
that we use to
see if our models are
you know
privacy
security
fairness anti you know money laundering
all of that
we are creating indicators
that
i call the human value index
risk
or the human engagement risk indicators
that aren't in
our normal risk factors right
that's what we're creating there are new
values that we're looking at that says
what is the risk of this model when it
engages with a human
and the human has
automation bias
the human has availability bias or the
human so now we're taking what we
understand about human cognitively the
cognitive biases we're having and we're
creating indicators from that to say
and this is over's term but it's it's
the human engagement risk so what are
the human engagement risk indicators
that we need to actually look at in our
input variables when we're
when we're collecting data when we're
creating features when we're creating
models
completely new stuff
yeah um and i think on top of that um
okay i guess there's no question for now
but um
um i think on top of the the things that
you say like but who is the right person
or the right team to say like this
values is the right values because like
i don't think like yeah
and that's why i say the teams have to
be transdisciplinary because it can't
just be the data scientists saying that
yeah what does he know about exactly
sociology
yeah like what does he know about how
humans congregate
or
uh
how human
or psychology like automation bias was
one i brought up
to
a data scientist who've created a model
where we're trying to make decisions
about xyz and i said
look
the human will be in the loop on those
first nine ten times but if the machine
doesn't make a mistake the human will
drop out
yeah because like and that's exactly
what happened with uber's self-driving
car she had been in that car for a
day for months
never had a mistake
she just backed out right because
we tend to we tend to have an automation
bias we trust machines that don't make
mistakes how often do you trust the
machine to get your checkbook right
yeah right you don't go around auditing
your digital bank account yeah
so i think
these are people who understand this
needs to be in a room with people who
are building this stuff right
and so like for example
if we build a model that decides whether
we're going to sue somebody for
collections i'm like we need to have
somebody who has been sued for
collections in that yeah room
yeah the value of empathy is really like
um very important in these days and not
just especially
experience like i'm i want the person
who's been through that in that cold
designing which is why i say
co-participatory design the role of
designer will change it would just be
people who are going to be impacted by
these models
right yeah right alongside the person
making the model okay
thank you so much
yeah thank you for that question i think
it's very pertinent
okay thank you so much i we're over time
which is kind of okay wonderful but i
thank you so much for all your time and
thank you for this thanks for asking me
i enjoyed it bye